[Applaudissements]
et l'oscar est décerné à
metz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
était un homme féroce quelqu'un qui a
toujours défendu sa famille
en cette période dans ma vie
mon mais qu'en ce moment précis
je suis un gars super
vieux et me demande de faire et d'être
dans ce monde
mais
en faisant ce film un genou hawass j'ai
protégé lui nice
chine une des choses
les plus fortes est à la fois études et
l'ict la plus délicate que j'ai jamais
rencontrées ailleurs j'ai protégé aussi
scianna et des mines
l'actrice qui joue
venus et serena
[Applaudissements]
gordon et mike on me demande dans ma vie
puis pour d'aimer les uns et les autres
un tout petit pippo est de protéger tout
un chacun
on me demande aussi d'être là pour ma
communauté
nom de widou et je sais que quand on
exerce le métier que l'on exerce il faut
bien voir supporter les plaisanteries
les rumeurs une les mensonges
puis quand on est acteur respecté nu il
faut pouvoir
gérer le fait que certains ne vous
respecte pas il faut toujours faire
bonne figure
c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup plu
quand on est au sommet c'est là qu'on
est le plus en danger c'est là que le
diable bien vous saisir
moi j'ai envie
d'être un symbole de l'amour que j'ai
envie de dire merci
pardon j'ai postillonner j'espère que ça
se verra pas ou à la télévision
merci à venus williams serena
la famille williams merci beaucoup de
m'avoir confié
j'ai envie de battre ça précisément
l'ambassadeur
cette histoire d'amour de protection
j'ai envie de m'excuser à la gaîté mills
a tous une économie
le bureau fut membre est un moment
sublime
et
si je pleure c'est pas parce que j'ai
gagné et ce bar une récompense parce que
c'est pas moi c'est pas ça qui est
important pour moi ce qui est important
en deux puis se jeter la lumière sur
toutes les personnes les trésors ce
design les hennaya les deux minots
toutes les personnes de la division ce
sont les personnes qui ont travaillé sur
la méthode liam éteint la lumière aussi
sur l'histoire de la famille williams
[Applaudissements]
alors je sais c'est une limitation de la
vie de la réalité
on a dit que richard williams était un
père un peu fou j'ai l'impression aux
mecs du maître la même chose mais
l'amour ça rend fou
j'aimerais aussi avoir une pensée pour
traverse une période difficile donc
évidemment je pense à elle
ne pouvait pas venir ce soir parce
qu'elle a son son club son club de
couture
voilà j'aime ma mère wife j'aime ma
famille j'ai
trop de temps
thank you for
merci beaucoup pour cet honneur que vous
me laissez moi
merci pour cet instant sur 7 vers si tu
te williams à toute la famille williams
sans
merci j'espère que
l'académie mains d'être à nouveau merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
il